we're asked to graph the function f of X
is equal to 5x minus 4 and we'll do it
by really just sampling some points from
the domain and seeing what value our
function takes and then we'll just graph
those points and then we'll just connect
the dots and see what forms and there's
other ways to do this but this is kind
of the most simple or the most basic way
so if you look at this function right
over here it's actually defined for any
real number that you stick there for X
so when we talk about sampling the
domain we can actually pick any real
number for X I'm actually going to pick
real numbers that are fairly small in
magnitude so that they're easy to graph
so I don't have to plot you know 8
billion on a number line over here so
let's draw ourselves some simple graph
paper let's call that the x-axis let's
call that the y-axis or actually I
should call it the y is equal to f of X
so I whatever my X is I input it into
this function definition it'll tell me
what the function value is there it'll
tell me f of X and we're going to say Y
is equal to that now let's draw a little
table here to try out some values so
let's say that this is X values and then
this is f of X and I can even say this
is my Y values which are going to be
equal to which are going to be equal to
f of X so let's start with I'm going to
try negative 2 negative 1 0 1 and 2
so let's try negative 2 first if I if X
is equal to negative 2 what is f of X
well f of X is going to be 5 times
negative 2 minus 4 so it's 5 times
negative 2 minus 4 which is equal to
negative 10 minus 4 which is negative
which is negative 14 so let me plot that
over here and let me actually make a I'm
going to have a slightly more scrunched
up scale on the y-axis I'm actually let
me give myself some space so that I can
go further down let me clear this give
myself a little bit of space because I'm
a feeling that I'll be using a lot of
negative values since I just got all the
way down to negative 14 so let me go
further down here and then let me mark
off some increments over here so let's
say that this
is let's say that this is negative 5
this is negative 10 and this is negative
15 negative 15 and then this if we this
would be positive 5 and then this would
be positive 10 so we have what X is
negative 2 when X is negative 2 f of X
is equal to negative 14 f of X is equal
to f of X is equal to negative 14 which
is right about there so that is negative
14 so that right over there is the point
negative 2 negative 14 which we got
right from that now let's try another
point let's try negative 1 when X is
negative 1 f of X is 5 times negative 1
minus 4 5 times negative 1 is negative 5
minus 4 is negative 9 so when X is
negative 1
f of X is negative 9 so negative 9 is
right about here so this is negative 9
so this is the point negative 1 negative
9 that is on the graph of f of X and now
let's try 0 when x is 0 f of X is going
to be 5 times 0 minus 4 well that's just
0 minus 4 which is equal to negative 4
so when x is 0 f of X is equal to
negative 4 so that's negative 4 right
over there and actually our point is
going to be sitting right over there
that is 0 negative 4 over to the left of
the point let's keep going that's what
happens when X is equal to 1 when X is
equal to 1 f of X is equal to 5 5 times
1 minus 4 5 times 1 is 5 minus 4 is
equal to 1 so we get to the point 1 1 so
1 and then 1 is right about there so
this is the point 1 1 and then let's
just try one more let's see what happens
when when X is equal to 2 then f of X is
5 times 2 minus 4 5 times 2 minus 4
which is 10 minus 4 which is equal to
which is equal to 6 so we have 1x
is equal to two f of X is equal to six
so it's right about there that's that
six right there so this is the point two
comma 6 so once again these are just
sample points from the domain this isn't
the entire domain but it gives us enough
points to kind of see the general
structure of the graph if we connect the
dots we see a line forming so if we
connect the dots
let me draw so if we connect the dots it
looks it looks something like this and
my shaky hand makes it look a little bit
curvy but it should be an absolute
straight line if I had this on really
good graph paper and I have had a ruler
you would see that this is a straight
line and it would keep going on and on
and on and I want to make it clear that
we just sampled points from the domain
but we could take any point in the
domain which we already said is all real
numbers so if we took right over here if
we said 1.5 you could see and if you
graph 1.5 f of 1.5 it should sit on that
line right over there if you graphed F
of negative 0.5 so this is negative 0.5
if you graphed F of negative 0.5 it
should sit on the line right over there
but we're done we have graphed the
function f of X is equal to 5x minus 4